>> Mark: NATION OF ISLAM
LEADER LOUIS FARRAKHAN HAS
HUNG OUT WITH COUNTLESS
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BIG SHOTS
INCLUDING BARACK OBAMA ONCE
UPON A TIME.
HE HAS ALSO SPENT DECADES
SPEWING HATEFUL RHETORIC TO
ANYBODY WHO WILL LISTEN TO
HIM.
>> YOUR COUNTRY HAS BEEN
TAKEN FROM YOU BY THE
SYNAGOGUE OF SATAN.
>> YOU COME TO TAKE OUR LIFE
DON'T BE SURPRISED IF YOU
LOSE YOUR OWN.
FARRAKHAN WANT TO GET AN
ARMY TO KILL WHITE PEOPLE
BECAUSE YOU SEE WHITE PEOPLE
DESERVE TO DIE.
>> Mark: YEAH, WHITE PEOPLE
DESERVE TO DIE THANKS FOR
THAT TIP.
VICTOR HANSON A SENIOR
FELLOW AT THE HOOVER
INSTITUTION, CONGRESSMAN
TODD ROKITA FROM INDIANA HAS
JUST SPRUCED A RESOLUTION IN
THE HOUSE TO CONDEMN
FARRAKHAN.
CONGRESSMAN, AS FAR AS THIS
RESOLUTION IS CONCERNED,
KEITH ELLISON FROM
MINNESOTA, FOR EXAMPLE, WHO
IS ONE OF FARRAKHAN'S
CLOSEST CONGRESSIONAL
ALLIES, SAYS THIS WHOLE
THREATENING IS GOING
NOWHERE, NOBODY CARES ABOUT
FARRAKHAN AND HE CAN GET
ALONG WITH COZYING UP TO
FARRAKHAN AS MUCH AS HE
WANTS.
>> IT'S COMPLETE HYPOCRISY,
MARK.
YOU POINTED IT OUT,
DR. HANSON HAS POINTED IT
OUT.
THIS NEWS ORGANIZATION HAS
POINTED IT OUT.
WHERE IS THE REST OF THE
MEDIA.
THIS LIBERAL MEDIA ELITE
THAT LET'S ALL THIS GO BY.
YOU KNOW, IF THIS HAPPENED
TO A REPUBLICAN, YOU KNOW,
IF THERE WAS SOME MEETING
LIKE, THIS WE WOULDN'T LAST
ONE DAY IN OFFICE.
AND ALL THE NEWS MEDIA WOULD
COVER IT FROM NOW UNTIL THE
ELECTIONS AND BEYOND IT'S
ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS.
ONE OF THE REASONS I
INTRODUCED THE RESOLUTION.
>> Mark: AND WHEN THEY TALK
ABOUT DAVID DUKE, DAVID DUKE
HAS GOT THREE FOLLOWERS, ONE
OF WHICH IS HIS DOG WHEREAS
FARRAKHAN HAS HUGE
POPULARITY WITH NOT JUST
WITH THE BLACK COMMUNITY,
BUT ALSO AT HIGH LEVELS OF
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
VICTOR, WHAT'S ODD TO ME IS
THAT FARRAKHAN SEEMED TO GO
AWAY FOR A LONG TIME.
HE SEEMED LIKE SOMETHING TO
DO WITH THE MILLION MAN
MARCH WHICH IS 20 YEARS AGO,
AND HE SEEMED MIRED IN THE
PAST AND THEN SUDDENLY YOU
FIND OUT THE WOMEN'S MARCH
THE COOLEST PEOPLE AROUND AT
THE MOMENT.
THEY PROTEST TRUMP.
THEY WEAR THE PINK HATS AND
ALL THE LEADERS OF THE
WOMEN'S MARCH ARE SOMEHOW
PLUGGED INTO FARRAKHAN IS HE
KIND OF STILL CURRENT, ISN'T
HE?
>> IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE WE
HAVE KNOWN FOR THREE DECADES
THAT HE APOWSED RACISM AND
ANTISEMITISM.
WHY AT 84 DOES HE HAVE THIS
NEW APOCALYPTIC LANGUAGE.
HE DIDN'T JUST SAY THAT
EXPRESS RACISM.
HE USED TERMS LIKE GOING
DOWN AND IT'S OVER.
73 YEARS AFTER THE HOLOCAUST
HE SAID THE ERA OF THE JEW
IS OVER.
TRANSFORMATION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF OLD TO
THE NEW IDENTITY POLITICS
PROGRESSIVE PARTY, HE IS
USEFUL.
HE IS NOT AL A BA CROSS
AROUND SOMEBODY'S NECK.
IS HE A USEFUL ASSET.
YOU CAN REALLY SEE THAT YOU
MENTIONED THE WOMEN'S MARCH
MS. PEREZ AND SARSOUR AND
MALLORY.
GOSH, WHEN DANNY DAVIS A
CONGRESSMAN SAYS THAT NOBODY
CARES ABOUT FARRAKHAN.
SEMITIC DEBATE AND PROPER
PLACE OF VIEW OF THE JEW US.
IN THE HANDS OF THE THIRD
RIGHT.
THE JEWISH QUESTION
HOLOCAUST.
HAVE A CONGRESSMAN TALKING
ABOUT THE JEWISH QUESTION IN
2018.
IT'S ABSURD AND JUST
REFLECTS, YOU MENTIONED
BARACK OBAMA'S PHOTO OP.
BUT EVEN MORE INTERESTING
THE PHOTOGRAPHER WHO TOOK
THAT WAS BEWILDERED BECAUSE
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY WANTED
TO SUPPRESS IT WAS COMMON OF
KNOWLEDGE NATION OF ISLAM
WORKED ON THE SENATE
CAMPAIGN.
>> IT'S RIDICULOUS THAT I
EVEN HAVE TO INTRODUCE THIS
RESOLUTION.
IT'S AN EASY QUESTION.
DO YOU CONDEMN ANTISEMITISM?
PARTY AS THE DOCTOR POINTS
OUT CAN'T ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
>> RIGHT.
>> Mark: VICTOR, IT SEEMS TO
BE A BY PRODUCT OF IDENTITY
POLITICS.
THAT WHAT MATTERS IS WHO YOU
ARE.
SO THAT IF A WHITE MAN SAYS
THIS KIND OF STUFF, HE IS
ALT RIGHT.
IS HE PART OF THE PROBLEM AT
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
TRUMP IS CALLED ON TO
DENOUNCE HIM.
IF FARRAKHAN SAYS THIS, HE
CAN SAY EXACTLY THE SAME
THINGS AND FARRAKHAN'S
IDENTITY ABSOLVES HIM
ENTIRELY FROM IT.
>> IT DOES.
IT'S VERY SCARY BECAUSE IN
THE CASE OF THE WOMEN'S
MARCH, WE HAVE AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN WOMAN.
WE HAVE HISPANIC WOMAN.
WE HAVE AN ARAB AMERICAN
WOMAN AND THEY ALL FEEL THAT
THEY GET SPECIAL
DISPENSATION TO COLLUDE WITH
SOMEBODY WHO IS AN OBVIOUS
RACIST, ANTI-SEMITE.
AND MEMBERS OF THE BLACK
CAUCUS WHO, REMEMBER,
OBAMA'S PHOTO OP. TOOK PLACE
IN THE CAPITOL IN THE
BASEMENT OF THE U.S.
CAPITOL.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> PEOPLE FEEL THEY ARE
COMPLETELY EXEMPT TO EITHER
COLLUDE WITH OR TO SUPPORT
TORE TO DISMISS THIS RACISM.
AND IT'S GOING TO CREATE --
IT JUST CREATES A PROBLEM OF
CYNICISM THAT NOBODY REALLY
DOES BELIEVE IN ANYMORE
BECAUSE THE REAL QUESTION IS
WHAT IS THEIR AGENDA?
DO THEY AGREE WITH FARRAKHAN
OR DO THEY NOT AGREE WITH
HIM?
THEY JUST NEED TO TELL US,
THAT'S WHY I REALLY APPLAUD
THE CONGRESSMAN'S EFFORT.
WE NEED TO ASK THEM THAT
QUESTION.
>> Mark: WHITE PEOPLE
DESERVE TO DIE, YOU CAN'T
GET ANY MORE SPECIFIC THAN